one of the great gifts my mom gave me
was she taught me that anything that you
want to know anything that you want to
be any problem that you have can be
solved from a book books give you access
to other people's wisdom other people's
experience and the wisdom of the ages
for that matter certainly we would start
for those of us that are Christians with
the Bible as the book of books God's
work but past that what are you reading
what are you spending your time on
something happens when you read it's
different the television is different
than listening to a podcast of a
motivational speaker or a great sermon
it's different than doing something
while you're exercising if you will sit
in a quiet space even if it's on an
airplane with your headphones on you
create your own quiet space and read
iPads okay Kindles okay paperback book
hardback book better there's something
that happens to your spirit connecting
to your brain and you will begin to have
other thoughts and I think it's because
we're all so busy and phonetic we don't
think anymore and this is the only time
you stop and think and in the weirdest
thing happens to me when I'm reading a
book I was reading a book not long ago
about finance about personal finance
another writer on that and I'm reading
through the book and it was good
and there were some interesting turns of
phrases made me think a little different
about how to verbalize a saint a concept
I've talked about before how to
communicate it
even though I really wasn't learning
like tons and tons of things from that
book I started having great ideas I
started filling up a yellow pad with
ideas because what was happening is my
brain was being stimulated and when
you're just listening the radio or you
listening to you know I Heart Radio I
which I do I love them and that's fine
there's a downtime for your brain tour
you're watching some television show
your brain is not engaged and when you
engage your brain in a quiet setting
where there's not a bunch of ad D
interruptions and you're in your space
and if you'll do that for 30 minutes
you'll be amazed at what happens and so
I'll tell you this there are no leaders
that aren't readers if you want to be a
leader in your field you have to be
reading you have to be reading something
all the time now I don't read like I
used to I used to read very slowly very
deliberately I was taking notes like I
was in class and really making sure I
grasped every kernel on every page and I
read a lot more too I read I would read
a book or two nonfiction a month back in
the day I don't do that now
I tend to just blow through a book
because I've written so many and I know
so many authors and I got so many books
to put on my desk there's no possible
way to get through all of them but still
I tend to just I tend to watch over I
can read it's not really speed reading
it's just skimming and but I'll still
occasionally I'll find one that I slow
down but even in that skimming or if you
slow down you're going to get ideas
because
your mind is a disengaged from the world
from all the problems that are out there
all the things that are coming at you
and so if you want to win in the area
parenting read a parenting book you want
to read you want to win with your
marriage read a marriage book you want
to get in better shape read a book about
physical fitness and nutrition you want
to grow spiritually start reading the
great minds and thought leaders the
theologians over the ages it's amazing
what it'll do to your mind let me just
tell you that there are no millionaires
who could tell you who got thrown off
the island that our brains are rotting
away with entertainment in this culture
and so leaders in any field in in the
area of life are all readers you want to
win be a reader